あれはたしか、、、
二年前の話だ
あのころからもやし男、もやし男と呼ばれ
その屈辱を晴らすべく
キング牛丼に手を出した
だが、食べることはできなかった
まぁ、結果的に全部食べてたんですけど
あれ実は２、３時間かかっていまして
あんなの食べた内にはいらーーん！！！
それから私はもやし、もやしと罵られ今に至る
こんにちわ！はじめしゃちょーです！
あれから２年が経った俺は強くなり
力を手に入れ
本物の神となった
あの頃の俺とは違うということを
俺をもやしと罵る人間全員に今日は
俺が進化した姿を
見せてやる！！！
そんなねぇ、痩せてないですよ
まぁ、痩せてますけど！
痩せてますけど
ガリガリじゃなくてやせ型ぐらいですよ
やせ型ぐらいです
今日は、キング牛丼にリベンジしたいと思います
あの頃は本当にただのもやしだった
もう食が細すぎて全然食べれなかったんですけども
お菓子を食べなくなってから食欲がすごいんですよ！
まぁ、人並みにね
食欲が人並みにすごいんで
なんかね、食べれますよたぶんキング牛丼
今日はもうあの頃の鬱憤を晴らす
ご覧ください、メガ牛丼2つです
いやいける！俺絶対いけるから！
今日はマジでいける！
なに安心せい！あの頃の俺とは違う、、
というわけで、キング牛丼普通では頼めないんですけど
サイズ的にはメガ牛丼二つ分らしいです
いよっしゃ、いくぜぇ！
見せてやるからな俺、今日は！
みんな約束してくれよ
俺がもし今日、このキング牛丼を食べきったら
俺のことはもう“もやし”と呼ばないでくれ、、
もう“もやし”と呼ばせないからな
ひとまず、かたち的に全部移します、こっちに
いや、もうあの頃の俺とは違う
レベルが違いますから
はい、というわけでキング牛丼でございます！
倒す！！！！
見とけよ！
この、このガリガリ、、あ、違う
細身の俺が
キング牛丼を食べる栄光の瞬間を
いただきます！！！
あ、木下さんのＢＧＭ流しておこう
あ～～、あっｒｒｒｒ
あら、おいしそうなお肉ねぇ
いっただきます～
おいしい～～！！
いやもう本当に食べるからね
味噌汁もおいしいと、おいしいと、、、
まだ行けますよ
まだ行けますよ！
まだ行けますよ！！！
たぶん半分はいったと、、
はぁ、はぁ、はぁ
まだいける！！！！
負けてらんね
俺は今日何としてでも食う
そして、もう！！
もやしと呼ばせねぇ～～！！！
だはぁ～～～
なめてた
あとほんの少しなんですけどラストスパートがやばい
もうラストスパートです！
ラスト～～
はぁ、くぁ、、わぁあ...
んん、んんんん、んんんん！！